[Música]
quisiera que pensáramos en el siguiente
caso es un caso hipotético pero cercano
a la realidad
se trata de pelo
pedro es un jornalero
que vive en el estado de puebla
que tiene cuatro hijos siempre vivido en
su comunidad que nunca ha salido del
país que no tiene antecedentes penales y
que como muchísimos mexicanos vive en un
estado de extrema pobreza
un día se acerca el compadre de pedro y
le ofrece una labor
manejé una pipa cada dos semanas para
transportar gasolina durante la noche
le insinúa que si no colabora su familia
podría tener empresarias
pero no sabe mucho del negocio no sabe
para quién trabaja y se ve forzado a
aceptar el trabajo por las
circunstancias
una noche en el trayecto a tula pedro es
detenido la gracia y la policía federal
los lleva ante un juez de control se le
acusa de cometer un delito en materia de
hidrocarburos enfrenta una posible
condena de 2 a 4 años
es evidente que en un caso como este
pedro será vinculado a proceso si el
ministerio público hace medianamente
bien su trabajo será muy fácil demostrar
que era transportada gasolina de manera
ilegal y que por lo tanto cometió un
delito hasta aquí no hay debate
el problema es que deberíamos hacer con
pedro una vez que se le vincula al
proceso en el modelo actual el que
deriva de la reforma de 2008 y que
introdujo el sistema penal acusatorio
los jueces tienen que las circunstancias
específicas a fin de determinar cuál es
la medida cautelar que se aplique al
caso concreto
recuerdo que el código nacional de
procedimientos penales contempla 14
medidas cautelares reiteró 14
es una amplia variedad de posibilidades
la pretensión en domicilio él
de dispositivos electrónicos
y mantenerlo en una localidad que se
presente periódicamente ante el juez de
la autoridad y los jueces pueden imponer
una o varias y este del ministerio
público decide al juez
cuáles son las medidas necesarias en su
caso la prisión preventiva pero esto
como una de las posibilidades cuando las
circunstancias así lo ameriten
el caso que les comento es muy probable
que pedro requiera medidas cautelares
pero muy probablemente por su condición
socioeconómica por su arraigo en su
comunidad por las circunstancias no sea
necesario que lo envíen a prisión
preventiva habría diferentes
alternativas
sin embargo quienes reformaron la
constitución piensen diferente
para ellos siempre bajo cualquier
circunstancia pero que cualquier otra
persona que cometa ese delito tendría
que ser enviado a prisión preventiva
cualesquiera que fueran las
circunstancias
regresemos y lo olvidamos a nuestro
viejo sistema penal aquel que teníamos
antes de 2008 que tenía a las cárceles
llenas de personas sin sentencia
mayormente por delitos menores y que
solamente subsidiaba la ineficiencia de
los fiscales y las policías para
realizar una buena investigación quienes
piensan que el reforma a la prisión
preventiva oficiosa es un remedio contra
la impunidad me parece que se equivocan
gravemente
olvidan
lo que se trata es de disciplinar la
manera en que el estado utiliza el
monopolio de la violencia legítima y
como lo he dicho uno de los teóricos del
estado más importantes reinos y perú
siempre es ambivalente así como un
estado tiene para proteger eficazmente a
sus ciudadanos también lo tiene para
oprimirlo y por eso es un poder que hay
que disciplinar y por eso existe el
principio de presunción de inocencia es
decir que nadie puede ser sentenciado
sin llevar un proceso con una evidencia
probatoria que permite aprobar su
culpabilidad más allá de la duda
razonable
su reforma fue un incremento muy notable
de los delitos que merecen prisión
preventiva oficiosa teníamos siete y ya
me parecía mucho lo llevamos a 16 tipos
en la pantalla pueden ustedes apreciar
el resultado de esta y algunos como robo
de casa habitación que ameritaría o el
caso que les expuse prisión preventiva
oficiosa se argumentó esto está en los
dictámenes de esta reforma que ésta era
una medida necesaria para citó el
espíritu garantista de nuevos sistemas
de justicia penal cierro la cita como si
el respecto al debido proceso ya los
derechos fundamentales son incompatibles
con una justicia penal eficaz y
eficiente
también se dijo que el estado debe
contar con mejores instrumentos para
proteger los derechos de la sociedad
como si la prisión preventiva- oficiosa
por sí misma un instrumento que
realmente permitiera una reducción en la
incidencia criminal todo esto es parte
de un discurso un discurso que conocemos
como el populismo penal que omite que
olvida que desde principios de este
siglo a principios de el 2000 la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
primero y después nuestra suprema corte
de justicia identificó que la prisión
preventiva oficiosa
severa que se le puede aplicar a un
imputado de un delito simplemente porque
no se ha demostrado su culpabilidad que
estamos frente a una medida de carácter
excepcional que puede ser eficaz cuando
las circunstancias así lo determinan
pero que no se puede aplicar como una
medida de carácter ordinario
olvida la historia y olvidan como les
decía que antes de la reforma de 2008
las cárceles estaban llenas de inocentes
pero no va a estar otra forma quizás con
buenas intenciones pero con un enorme
desconocimiento de la realidad olvidan
que el resultado va a ser que muchos
inocentes y muchos pobres van a acabar
en la cárcel y no así quienes realmente
se benefician de las grandes redes de
corrupción y de la delincuencia
organizada
se desconoce el costo que tiene que
pagar el estado mexicano en tener un
sistema penitenciario saturado y al
borde del colapso
una auténtica universidad del crimen
de acuerdo con la información de energía
que ustedes pueden ver en esta gráfica
aún sin presión preventiva oficiosa
teníamos un número muy significativo de
personas privadas en libertad sin
prisión digo sin sentencia y 2016 lo ven
ustedes aquí ya la población privada de
libertad sin sentencia era superior a
aquella que tenía gente por otro lado la
evidencia que tenemos es contundente el
modelo de prisión preventiva justificada
si funciona tienen aquí dos de el
consejo de la judicatura federal para
2018 son tres delitos y estos tres
delitos representan poco más del 80 por
ciento de la incidencia delictiva
federal y en ustedes las cifras de
prisión preventiva quiere decir que
cuando los ministerios públicos piden
prisión preventiva
los jueces tienden a conceder la no es
cierta la historia de la puerta
giratoria es un problema distinto que
tiene que ver con la actuación previa
el ministerio público mucho menos la de
los jueces
porque entonces optar por la prisión
preventiva- oficiosa porque insistir en
esta reforma porque a pesar de todos los
que comparecimos y dijimos que era una
muy mala idea no les importó y aprobaron
la reforma por esta idea del populismo
último
en el sistema acusatorio los delitos
graves no existen el uso de este
lenguaje demuestra el profundo
desconocimiento que como sociedad
tenemos de la forma en que opera este
sistema sabemos que la prisión
preventiva automática no mejora las
investigaciones y subsidia significa su
estructura de policías y fiscalías
sabemos que la prisión preventiva
oficiosa no reduce la impunidad ni sirve
para combatir el crimen organizado
sabemos sí que de esta prisión tiene un
impacto desproporcionado en las personas
de menores recursos
por alguna razón se ha expandido el mito
de que la prisión preventiva- oficiosa
solamente se puede aplicar a los delitos
que están en el artículo 19 esto es una
falacia esto es mentira el sistema
permite perfectamente que los jueces
dicten prisión preventiva cuando la
circunstancia lo determinen en cualquier
delito que tenga pena de cárcel
y la prisión preventiva- oficiosa me
parece que es una medida claramente
regresiva y que contraviene el artículo
9 de la declaración de derechos civiles
y políticos que dice la prisión
preventiva de las personas que hayan de
ser juzgadas no debe ser la regla
general y con ello con ello abrimos un
debate de si esta reforma constitucional
puede ser considerada in convencional
porque insisto seguimos en esta idea
punitiva probablemente porque nuestra
cultura jurídica una cultura jurídica
hecha en la prisión preventiva nos dice
que el cualquier delito y que la única
sanción efectiva o una casa de sanción
justa es la cárcel y se nos olvida que
justamente la reforma de 2010 y de 2008
quería romper ese paradigma y quería
poner los acentos en medidas
reparatorias en la reparación de las de
las víctimas en la rehabilitación y en
medidas cautelares y evitar que todo el
mundo estuviera en las cárceles que
repito son las grandes universidades del
crimen
como ha escrito el actual presidente de
la suprema corte de justicia de la
nación el ministro arturo saldívar del
estado derecho no se adelante en las
penas no se sanciona antes de controlar
de condenar
la respuesta profunda me temo es que
como sociedad como gobierno los partidos
políticos no nos hemos hecho cargo de lo
que realmente importa la solución a la
crisis de seguridad que vive méxico está
necesariamente por la construcción de
policías y fiscalías eficaces y
eficientes que respeten los derechos
humanos con un modelo sólido de
investigación y con capacidad para
llevar procesos exitosos
por supuesto y una tarea mayúscula y una
tarea que requiere recursos
perseverancia a largo plazo sentido de
estado
sin duda habrá tropiezos y habrá
aprendizajes y se necesitan funcionarios
capaces de planear e implementar una
política criminal de largo plazo y de
políticos que sean capaces de conducirla
esta es la condición indispensable no
salidas falsas como la de la la que se
ha hablado
se invitó entonces a mantener esta
reflexión y los invito a que como
mandata un transitorio de la reforma
constitucional probablemente la única
buena idea que tomaron los diputados y
los senadores es que en cinco años
tendríamos que estar evaluando el
resultado de esta reforma para saber si
efectivamente construimos un mejor
estado de derecho muchas gracias
[Aplausos]